There's an old saying that advises performers
to never work with children or animals.
After all, they both lack the self-control
of adult humans, and if they don't feel like
working, they just won't.
Here are some films in which animals wreaked
havoc while the cameras were rolling.
Mr. Popper's Penguins
Jim Carrey loves to goof around on the set,
riffing on lines, making outrages sounds,
and teasing co-stars.
"Scooba-dee-ba-da-bop bop bop.
Honk.
Honk!"
It's all part of the Jim Carrey package.
But if he messes around a bit too long, not
all of Mr. Popper's penguins are gonna put
up with it.
"I'll introduce you, somebody wants to talk."
"Wanna say 'hi'?"
"Ohh yeah!"
"Go this way...
OK.
Know what?
Sometime we need a little… hey, come here,
come here, no!"
Outlander
This historical TV series is full of serious,
dramatic moments set on the battlefields of
18th-century Scotland.
But behind the scenes, certain actors march
to beat of their own drum — and go by their
own schedule.
Take for example, the horse who didn't feel
like waiting until the scene was finished
to take care of personal business.
"Oh yes, quite enough."
The Lone Ranger
Disney's attempt to reboot The Lone Ranger
was also an attempt to revive the old-school
big-screen Western.
As a result, Armie Hammer and Johnny Depp
spend large portions of the movie on horseback.
All that time together led to what looks like
an on-set romance…or at least a crush.
"I love you..."
"You have traveled far."
"Okay don't come, see if I care."
"Marker, marker!"
Anchorman
In the ridiculous classic Anchorman, Will
Ferrell's character Ron Burgundy winds up
a shell of a man located in, well,
"I'm in a glass case of emotion!"
And it's all because he threw a burrito out
the window and hit a biker, who responded
by punting Ron's beloved dog, Baxter, off
a bridge.
But behind the scenes, it appears the "actor"
playing Baxter could sense the danger ahead.
"Cuz I will give you a rap on the Jack Johnson!
You hear me?!"
"Yep.
Now this is going to happen!"
"Yep, he doesn't like you."
Anchorman 2
The beginning of Anchorman 2 shows Ron getting
the old news team from Anchorman back together.
He finds Paul Rudd's character, ace reporter
Brian Fantana, working as a highly esteemed
kitten photographer.
But some on-the-set tension between the "models"
may have led to some, well, cat fights.
"Ohhhh!"
The Interview
German Shepherds are one of the most fearsome
breeds of dog, liable to maim, murder, and
dismember if they're trained that way.
Or, apparently, that rage can be re-directed.
Unfortunately for Seth Rogen in The Interview,
the scenes he shot with an extremely friendly
German Shepherd also required nudity.
The
Hangover
Dogs are essentially professional people-lickers.
While filming The Hangover, Zach Galifianakis
established a very special bond with a dog
named Tucker, although, it doesn't seem like
it was always the dog who was doing the licking.
"I love you so much!"
"I've got so much peanut butter in my beard
right now."
The Proposal
You'd think acting opposite Oscar-winning
movie star and America's sweetheart Sandra
Bullock would get actors to behave professionally
and keep a laser focus on their scene partner.
Apparently, not all actors.
"Come on ya little…"
Late Night with Conan O'Brien
During a taping of an episode of his old NBC
show in 2007, Conan O'Brien brought out a
duck, without a plan as to what to do with
it.
Well, the duck had his own idea.
The
bit was so well-received that O'Brien brought
the duck back, naming him "Quackers, the s---eating
duck."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!